im sue cervini and I have been a part of
this college for of more years than I
can guess my grandfather was a trustee
in the early 50s and then my dad foul
suit became a trustee so it's been a
family affair been involved with the
Hillsdale Garden Club he'll sell women's
clothes I am past president we've hosted
the hills to hostile party's done the
trustee parties and one year John was
without an event planner Jeanne
Kirkpatrick was to speak for us down in
Palm Beach my mom and i planned that
entire dinner at the breakers i'll never
forget it it was an elegant affair when
John and I were first married I was
still working in the toledo area i
decided to retire because we chose to
make our home in Hillsdale well then I
met the owner of a little shop downtown
called plums I started doing a fashion
seminars for her and then I started
working for Megan's I've done fashion
seminars and fashion shows for them for
20 years I bought an agency with
Doncaster and i have been selling and
promoting doncaster done quite well in
the state of Michigan I was
flabbergasted when Gregor called me to
ask if I would receive an honorary
alumnus award from hillsdale college and
it means absolute great deal to me I've
always felt a part of this college I
feel even more a part of it
this award so thank you from the bottom
of my heart